I mean booze and technology I mean
that's kind of we found our niche we get
to go to bars and nightclubs and show
off de technology get drunk we've been
involved with a group called Robo games
from in the years when you're there for
a long time to get the bug about
building machines building technology
and then one day I heard about cocktail
robotics and that's where the Cosmo box
again
so this is bartender oh it is our
cocktail robot and it's operated with a
smartphone or a tablet presents you with
a menu of about 50 different drinks that
you can make and you can adjust things
like the strength the sweetness we can
do 15 liquids and it washes itself which
means I could make probably as many
drinks as most general bars can just off
this one machine behind me most of the
robots made a lot of drinks kind of
reasonably well and I wanted to make
robots that made one drink really well
you've got a chance to kind of take back
technology and I think more and more we
feel as though technology is running us
and having a moment where you get to
take back technology and have it do one
of those things that that you really
wanted it to do I don't know it feels
good when it happens it's just really
efficient and you press a button and all
the all the liquids dispense at the same
time to give you a drink an awesome
cocktail the same way every time in
about five seconds there's a lot to be
said for craft cocktails and I've run a
craft cocktail bar and it's a great
thing but I think there's a whole nother
element when you add a robot to it the
robot side was actually easier than a
furniture making side it's more
determination than actual skill the
benefit of using robots is that you can
get the exact portioning but then the
next step is to make it do it with some
chef